meanwhile senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell has set a vote for
wednesday on a 500 billion dollar covet
financial relief measure which he calls
skinny
so how close is washington to finalizing
a coronavirus bill let's bring in
anita kumar politico's white house
correspondent and associate
editor so all right i need to listen you
know senator mcconnell he's offering a
500 billion dollar
coronavirus financial relief package
that would
provide funds to expand unemployment
benefits
another round of the paycheck protection
program
financial aid to schools and funding for
testing
and contact tracing now speaker pelosi
and treasury secretary
steve mnuchin as you know they're
currently in talks so if the two
though don't come up with anything
different can
the speaker afford to turn down the
senate majority leader's current deal
i don't think it's likely it's going to
pass uh past the house anyway because
she you know house speaker nancy pelosi
has already said time and time again
she's not going to
be willing to go for that this is pretty
much the same bill
the same proposal they had earlier and
she's already rejected that she says it
just doesn't go far enough and it
doesn't address a lot of the need so i
think it's
it's unlikely to get past the senate so
expound on some of the obstacles
oh there's so many and it changes every
day but
really the white house and the house
democrats do seem to be getting
close to something uh but they still
disagree
on some of those specific policies in
the bill so their number is getting
closer
how much they're looking at spending is
getting closer but they still
fundamentally disagree on how much
should go to states and localities
that's been one of the biggest sticking
points
from the very beginning they also
disagree about liability for businesses
you know should the businesses
um you know have protections uh when
people come in there with and get
coronavirus that sort of thing so that's
been one of the biggest issues
but even if the two sides agree and
that's a big if at this point
senate republicans just do not want to
spend that much money they have said
that from the very beginning
uh senate senate leader mitch mcconnell
said that just recently so i find it
really hard to believe that they would
would change that they feel that they
would lose their base
conservatives don't want to spend that
much they're worried about federal
government spending so it seems
it seems like that's really where the
where the obstacle is
i mean they've spent a lot of money for
sure uh and
i can understand why they are not trying
to spend even more money than necessary
but people are hurting
americans are hurting so i don't know
that there are a lot of people who the
ones who are hurting
and who are close to losing their
livelihood and don't have food on their
table or maybe being put out of their
homes i don't know that they are looking
at what the federal
uh deficit is at the moment they're
looking at the deficit in their own
you know accounts if they even have
accounts at this point so
wouldn't that be a consideration if
they're looking at a base or what how
it's going to affect voters
yeah i mean it's a great point and and
that's i think why we're seeing
two weeks and a couple days out from
this election both sides still sitting
down and trying to negotiate
it's it's incredible that they're this
close to an election and still trying to
do this
and that's exactly what you're saying
it's this pressure that they're feeling
back in their districts and their states
to get something done uh you know some
of these voters and americans don't care
if it's democrats or republicans
they just want washington to do
something they're kind of sick of the
whole thing so
i think they are feeling that pressure
back at home which is why we're seeing
them two weeks out
sitting down and talking uh treasury
secretary uh
steve mnuchin and the speaker is
supposed to talk again tomorrow so
you know we'll see if if they come up
with something well we hope both of us i
know for i am going to speak for you
right now
just for the sake of the people you know
i mean we're all americans we don't want
to see fellow americans
uh suffering let me wrap really quickly
with you anita
because you know senator mcconnell was
looking to get this coronavirus stimulus
light package passed and then move on to
a vote to confirm judge amy coney
barrett to the supreme court so you know
kind of it give them a
a one-two punch that could play out in
the in the favor of the president trump
and the republicans on the ballot
uh but if that doesn't happen you know
we'll if the stimulus package
doesn't happen do you think mcconnell
will move on to
uh the barrett vote he kind of i do
yes i do think so i mean this is they
have been full steam ahead
it's only been a month since ruth bader
ginsburg died but they
are moving quickly to do this they have
the votes they feel they have the votes
and they want that win uh before you
know the election which is in two weeks
so i think both the white house
and the senate are moving really
forcefully ahead on that i think you'll
see both of those votes this week
wow all right well maybe i'll talk to
you next week and anita kumar
and from politico take care thanks